uh yeah gentlemen we're live all right
all right so we have a special podcast
for you here today it's uh
the ultimate uh
fighter 2 heavyweight winner the former
ufc light heavyweight champion 2019
inducted into the ufc hall of fame the
one and only rashad evans brother it's
good to have you on man thank you truly
thank you for having me on guys yes it's
very good to have you on you know
i got to tell you guys a story yesterday
david text me over and over and over
again says pat i totally understand
gerard being in this podcast maybe even
adam but i i don't think tom fits for
this podcast
he's like what's tom gonna talk about
and i said listen let him be in there
you know tom's gonna maybe give a
different perspective but it's good to
be with you folks if you're tuning in
paul escarsiga who's one of our
wonderful fantastic editors who uh uh uh
is a great team player and creates jobs
for other people but he
paul uh got punched in the face by chuck
liddell you keep forgetting his name he
got punched in the face by chuck lavelle
a couple years ago we went to his house
and he wanted to find out how hard chuck
hit so he put the headgear on you put
the gloves on chuck hit him and he was
gone for a minute right
so he's trying to find out whether you
punch harder or he does and you said
you're committed to it yeah i'm
committed to it but here's the thing
like i don't i don't want to hurt the
dude i mean like
maybe don't go hundred percent okay okay
just just give a nice give him one for
him to feel it just for him to have some
memories of you when you leave
[Music]
david and paul got into it so he'd like
to see you knock his ass out anyway so
paul brace for impact we're going to do
it on the second half and then we're
going to watch
uh mazvidal street fighting video and
get some feedback from you maybe even a
commentary of what you see with a guy
like this fighting because i know we got
a he's got a fight coming up right he's
got a fight coming up with kobe curious
to know what you think about that he's
got a fight coming yeah i know he's got
also fight coming up of course but but
uh you know with that that right there
because of a mazda doll also with kobe
going out it would be curious and what
he says about it so rashad i um
i i've been to a lot of fights but you
had a fight coming up and i followed
your fights you were
you were something else been watching
your fight
we're the same age i think you and i are
maybe a year apart i don't know exactly
how old you're 40 talk i'm 43. so same
era i'm watching you're coming up i'm
just watching how you're fighting uh my
buddy elaine cooper who was one of our
vps in the company i took him to the
fight his birthday yesterday happy
birthday lynn cooper uh took him to go
watch you and jackson fight which was
insane to go watch you fight but walk us
through the past man how you got into
everybody's got a different story how
they get into the ufc what's your story
coming up uh well i was in lansing
michigan and uh i was um working at this
bar
and uh i was just graduated from college
and i was you know doing a little bit of
bouncing work and a fight broke out and
um i was a ufc fan back in the day and i
used to watch it back in 1993 when it
first came out
so it went through that dark area where
not a lot of people knew about it and
knew what was going on with it and the
fight broke out and the guy was like oh
man he put him in a rear naked choke now
when he said that it kind of like i was
like oh okay not many people know what
that was so then i started to inquire
you know okay you know how'd you know
what that was and then he said that he
trains nhb because it's called no holds
bar at the time
and i was like okay where you do that at
and he told me where he did it at and um
you know we went to the gym the
following monday
and it was this beat down run down like
dilapidated building and it had rats and
stuff in it and uh we go in there this
building and i'm thinking i'm about to
get set up and robbed i'm like oh man
this don't seem safe at all in michigan
in michigan
atlanta michigan it was just like a very
seedy area and uh we go to the room
where the train at and it's a little
small room like 12 by nine and these
guys are just beating the hell out of
each other they're just like taking
turns you know going against each other
just like full-on sparring just nothing
i ever seen before so uh i went and i
tried that day and i was like hooked so
i kept on going there and kept training
with those guys and then after a while
you know we just got tired of beating
the hell out of each other and it was
like a real life fight club like you
know it was like doctors lawyers and
like underground types underground type
of guys yeah and that's so that's what
we do for training but we were just
beating the hell out of each other so we
wanted some new meat and we started to
uh we linked that with dan severin and
dan severn was in coldwater michigan so
we started driving out to coldwater
michigan and training with those guys
now at the time dan severan was doing
his uh his fight promotion which was in
indiana angola indiana and on the indian
reservations because the ufc at the time
was only allowed to be in vegas and dan
was like i'm gonna have you know the
only show outside of uh of vegas you
know so we'll fight on these indian
reservations and uh dan dan severum was
inducted into ufc hall of fame
and then he said to me uh you know i
have an opportunity to have one of my
you know they'll look at one of my guys
uh but the thing about it is um you know
have you heard of the ultimate fighter
and i was like yeah i heard the ultimate
fight i watched the first season and
then he says okay uh well they're doing
a second season but it's heavyweights
though and he said you're way too small
you're like you know 195 pounds and i
was like i can be heavyweight so i just
started eating a lot of carbs and just
bulking up as big as i could get and
you know i got on the ultimate fighter
show
and from there uh
i won the ultimate fighter show and then
that's how my ufc career started but it
was uh you know started in lansing
michigan now were you were you a fight
like if we're in high school did you
have a reputation for a guy that don't
mess with rashad or did you have that
kind of reputation yeah i'll show you
in high school yeah at what age did
people know like at what age you knew
you could fight oh man probably like in
um
probably like in fifth grade i was
i was fighting for you or that dude in
fifth grade that's like oh he's gonna
roll up on you fifth grade well i mean
because i went i went to like a majority
white school so all those white boys
well i was always at target you know
what i'm saying you know they always say
stuff so i mean i i would fight on the
way home from school uh walking home
from school my brother would make me
fight people
he would make you fight people yeah
he'll tell me to fight him in what ways
that guy said something to you gonna go
fight him or yeah i mean if like
somebody like looked at me a certain way
like yo go fight him and if i had an
older brother oh the brother yeah
and if i didn't fight that guy then he
had beat me up so was he a fighter was
he a tough guy himself yeah he was a
tough guy yeah he sounds like he was
more like a promoter
all right go find that guy make his
lunch money yeah and you can beat that
guy we're gonna come here next week
is it because you were scared of your
older brother and didn't want him to
whup your ass was it just like you had
that itch inside what was that
relationship with your brother well i
mean you know i was scared of my older
brother but at the same time him and i
will fight all the time you know
and um you know we just we just grew up
how many years older is he than you he's
two years older this is like ticonderoga
so dylan yesterday for the first time
said something very weird to me and you
know he's taking classes right now he's
going to borrow three times a week two
times a week and he's his middle son is
just absolutely swim every day and he's
now doing soccer he's doing all these
other things like just one of these guys
that's very athletic like you see him
you're going to say sarah's going to
play something right the middle eastern
boat just like he just loves like he
loves fighting like there's something
about it that he likes he's eight years
old first time he's ever said something
like this says dad one day i'm going to
be the greatest fighter in the world i
was like what
he's never like he's never said i'm
going to be the greatest anything just
out of nowhere he just said daddy you
know what i i want to also learn how to
box i want to also learn how to do this
so by the way we got to keep this in
mind we don't watch videos like we don't
sit here and say let's watch this fight
video let's watch this youtube video
this guy's taking bara his coach has
inspired him and he says i want to be
the best fighter in the world one day so
it's i don't know if it's there or not
obviously a lot of kids probably have
said this before but he has that can i
say one thing about dylan you're we're
making him sound like he's some
tough like these sweetest nicest kids
yeah so the fact that he wants to be the
nut it makes no sense yeah because he
said it's almost like you you're such
like a just a sweet nice guy at least
from what i can tell so far well once
paul comes to your different side it's
going to show up but it's interesting
how do you balance like the sugar the
sweet side with just knocking mofos out
how does how does that duopoly work well
i mean it's uh you know
it's
i'd say whatever bothers me in life
and i just leave it for for the training
you know i learned at a at a young age
to kind of
um you know learn how to uh
put my frustrations into sports and
things like that so now i just become
second nature to me so outside in real
life you know i'm just kind of calm and
just relaxed and i can take a lot of
and then
when it comes it's a switch it's a
switch yeah so so okay so let's uh let's
go through uh one question that i had
for you is so
you're when you're 22 so you're when you
were 32 you fought uh
john who was 24. am i saying i correctly
was 32 32 to 24
and his reach was 84 and a half i want
to say you were 75 you know uh weight
obviously the same height he had you on
you know whatever however many inches he
has your honor because he's a taller guy
he's a 645 but he came through you were
like an older brother so you haven't
seen a different side of him he's nice
right now believe me richard's got a
different highlight
but but i want to talk to you but i want
to go back and ask a question here about
coming up so if you
were 22 today
and you know you can ball you know you
can hang in there you know like listen i
think i can take this guy down right i
can fight this guy but the comp
structure and the opportunities are
different today than they were when you
were 22 right you're seeing this whole
thing with jake paul and dana going back
and forth and hey pay him this and pay
him that and you're seeing what jake is
making you're seeing what woodley made
with a fight you're seeing what
mayweather is doing what conor did so
the model is different you got boxing
ground you got the youtube rod you got
the ufc rod what how different of a game
plan would you have today with your
wisdom today being 42 20 years older
than i mean 22.
what would you tell the 22 year old
rashad evans today which route to take
well i mean it's all about now um
getting the following you know we live
in such a culture right now where it's
all about the following and you know
getting the people's interests you know
whatever it may be that you do that
stands out among the crowd you know
accentuate that and really stand upon
that and really start to push yourself
in that direction and then from there
you know you can start to navigate which
fights that you want because you know
the promotion or whatever it may be
they're going to make sure that they put
you in a position where they can get the
return for your value because it's all
about the value you know people want to
pay you for what your value for if you
don't have the value you can be the best
fighter in the world but you're not
going to get that money
so so in other words
would you say
you'd be somebody that'd be documenting
your vlogs your fights your training to
get a youtube channel to get a few
million subscribers and then maybe
have some of the instagram how how would
you create that following would you take
the jake paul route would you take the
logan paul route would you take the con
around what what route would you take
you know uh there's somebody somebody
doing it really well right now uh
shigeshan o'malley he's he's uh sick
stole your nickname by the way yeah but
that's all right man we're going to run
up on that dude
it's all right though because the thing
about it is he's he's owning it you know
i'm saying he's making it his own and um
you know this kid if you watch him you
know uh can you pull him up so people
know who he is crazy hair white boy
skinny crazy hair white boy skinny uh
but he's a very interesting character
you know he um he's fun to look at he's
fun to look at but he's he's got
personality and he just he just comes to
life and and and what he does is not
only uh does he talk a good game um he
fights like crazy he knocks people out
even though i feel like his level of
competition should be a bit higher but
that's what happens when you have that
following when you have that following
they bring you along the right way
because they don't want to ruin you in
order before they get the full value out
of you and that's one thing that he does
really well he's really good on social
media he's really good uh with his
youtube breaking down fights and all
those things
and he just has the interest that you
know he speaks to the uh the demographic
of today and the huge following so you
would you would advise
you would like you yourself would still
go
the ufc route you would still go to ufc
route yourself if you were 22 today
except you would pay more attention to
the social media following or would you
say i'm going to go try to get part of a
you know de la hoya camp i'm going to go
part of canelo camp i'm going to go try
to be a boxer because that just pays
more you know canelo got a you know 12
fight 360 million auto contract whatever
the number was some insane number that
he got right i'm gonna go take that
route or no i'm gonna i'm gonna work my
way up on the ufc side and be the next
whoever what what what route would you
take i would say go to ufc route because
of the steal yeah well because of what
boxing is that
you know um for so long before you can
even get to that level i mean jake paul
has been able to do something
extraordinary because of the fact that
he's built himself up way high before he
even put himself in a position to box so
that's like an anomaly out of the whole
situation but you know with the ufc you
know you can start off and really grow
in an organization and and if you're
like a guy like sean o'malley they'll
bring you along the way and you can
develop your skills at the same time you
know by
and and develop who you are outside of
the cage as well too yeah i'm just very
very curious because you know a lot of
young guys see everybody and they're
kind of like what do i do now yeah what
route do i go now so you know you seen a
jake you know what was it did you see
the number that came out highest paid
athlete under 25. did you see that
million dollars 45 million dollars he
made last year highest paid athlete no
go to the one i want to say gerard
versus jake paul i want to see that the
highest paid athlete under 25 type in
under
uh
five days ago right there go back no
that's five years ago go back
it's the one right there jake paul um
put news go typing in the news yeah
cause it's right there click on that one
right at the top
go up it should show the list of people
go under the ads right there click on
that
uh is that the one or no
oh no because he's not a female go back
not yet
go up go keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going anyways he
made 45 million bucks last year that's
the number they put him as a highest
paid athlete under the age of 25. look
at his tweet right there if you go down
below what do you say
highest paid athlete under 25.
jake paul it's
an unsustainable model though because
not everybody can get in the ring and
actually take punches it's a very very
did the the promotional side of it
you're talking about sugar shane
o'malley and you know
the thing that sugar shane o'malley has
is world-class striking skills he's not
just a clown out there right you know
and they've done this with other guys
with all due respect i mean you know
they tried this with sage northcutt
right like they were like this guy's
gonna be captain america
and then they got him in the ring and
what happened right so i mean it takes a
a very very special type of human being
that wants to get in there and it's not
just the i mean he'll tell you better
than anybody else it's not it's not the
nine minutes in the ring it's the nine
weeks of sparring leading up to it and
if you don't do that yeah you know so i
mean
you're when you first were coming up
with dan severan that's crazy man i mean
you know did you ever consider like the
k-1 stuff and the pride fighting and
going overseas and all that also and
doing the grand prix yeah i actually
wanted to do that to do that first um
you know i was a big fan of rampage at
the time and i was a big fan of the
whole you know the whole japanese market
when it came to the uh the pride
fighting and i like the rules of kicking
each other in the head when they're down
i it felt like that was my style bastard
it felt like it was my style but um the
ufc came first and it was just you know
better opportunity because of the ufc
was growing at the time you know the
first season the ultimate fight was
really the birth on a um on a you know a
a big level for the ufc you know when it
comes to popularity and just coming out
the dark ages of of not knowing who it
was you know not knowing what it was so
being on the second season
uh i felt like i was part of something
at the ground level and uh just being
part of the ufc growing with them has
was been you know a huge experience you
won the second season right yeah and
when were you either waiting
one championship as a light heavyweight
but he won when were you the coach
uh season 10. season 10 and the other
coach was rampage
uh and you had brendan schaub on your
team who was on the podcast recently so
quick questions i see rampage i know you
you beat his ass that guy's got like the
scariest looking face ever like i see
that guy i don't mess with that guy
just quick thoughts on rampage and that
you guys got into it and then also
brennan shop who was on the podcast
thoughts on his career yeah me and
rampage it was a very uh highly uh hot
season you know him and i would go to
the point where
um we'll fight every single day you know
to the point where the production stat
was like hey guys i know you don't like
each other but you know you guys got to
find a way to calm down a little bit
because we got to be able to shoot the
scenes and stuff like that because it
was just like the first time in the
history of reality television the
production staffers are like why don't
you guys not yes
it was just unruly sometimes you know it
would get it'll get bad and uh you know
the talking though yeah you guys weren't
fighting you guys were no we were
talking smack but it came to a a a
couple of times where it was almost like
we were gonna fight you know the famous
door scene yeah the famous door scene
yeah so it got pretty contested uh quite
a bit but um that season was probably uh
the funnest season of the ultimate
fighter and uh you know looking back on
it
i can't let you get closer i mean that
was a good one too they actually fought
they actually scrapped that one but i
mean the the one being rampage it was
good because you know it built up from
the ultimate fighter season then he
didn't fight me because he had that
movie with uh um the a-team and then we
ended up fighting so it's a little bit
more of a build up to the actual fight
and it would you know it was a good
fight you know but now uh me and rampage
we got a chance to uh actually do a
movie together we did a movie together
um called boss level we played german
twins so we kind of got to a chance to
you know speak about what happened
before and you said german twins german
twins
do you have a good german accent what do
you think not at all
and then what about shobb uh brandon
schaub you know i knew brendan chop back
in the day when he was you know first
starting off with mixed martial arts you
know we would train out in denver with
uh trevor whitman and nate marquardt and
those guys you know it was like uh
jackson's gym and then we'll go to
keller
colorado and train at grudge gym and go
to tristar so we would go and train with
brendan chubb when he was first starting
off and uh when i when i found out i was
going to do the ultimate fighter season
you know i really a strong advocate for
getting him and
getting him into the show and um you
know brendan was phenomenal man brendan
was like you know diamond in a rough he
just didn't know how good he was you
know he was one of those guys who um i
honestly believe
um
had he not
went on a streak where he got caught a
couple times he could have been somebody
who really done something really yeah he
was brendan was good man brendan was
good man he uh
i know he had that tough talk with joe
rogan when joe rogan told him to sit
down but you know it's um
in the heavyweight division you can get
caught and knocked out you know it's
it's very easy for that to happen and at
some point you have to modify your game
you know you have to be able to
understand the fact that you can't sit
there and exchange blows like you can
at a smaller weight class so you have to
be able to be able to use different
tactics i mean you know throwing some
punches and doing a little bit of cage
wall and brawl and kind of just gumming
up the action a little bit more and not
doing so much of the you know standing
at the 50 50 and see who lands first
well rashad let me ask you that i mean
you came from a brawling background i
always thought you came from a wrestling
background but if you came from a
brawling background you know one of the
most impressive things is when a fighter
switches it and they go from being able
to inflict damage to being able to not
let someone inflict damage i mean one of
the things with floyd mayweather i think
is one of the most impressive things he
never gets credit for
this guy for 20 years had the best in
the world trying to hurt him and he just
wouldn't let them defense like he was
completely
that's like the art of it right so i
mean when did you and your career go
from switching that mentality from like
dude i can hurt these dudes too you know
what these guys can't hurt me i know
exactly what to do to stop them from
from getting me um well i started to use
all my attributes you know at one point
you know you kind of fall into the style
because you coached by different people
and you want to do you know what they're
telling you to do but then you have to
realize what makes you unique and what
made me me unique was the fact that i
was able to move you know i was very
shifty very high energy at this point
very high energy so i i utilized my
movement more and then when i could i'll
utilize my grappling and you know jam up
the action so i wasn't sitting there
just you know throwing punches with
these big dudes because at the end of
the day you get caught with one of those
big shots and you you you're not gonna
be standing for too long you caught by
too many because these four ounce gloves
are a very you know not much padding in
them at all and then underneath the four
of gloves it's like you have a cast on
because your your hands are wrapped so
it's a very uh very strong you just saw
that with steep a and in ghana right
like i mean stipe is trying to control
the pace and and ghana's just waiting
only needs that one right hand and
especially with a guy like in ghana he
got that an accidental power where he
just like he just moves around and he
just knocks that the baddest man on the
planet right now agano yeah i mean he he
is man and gano is something special
that's your number one baddest man on
the planet right now i would say so i
would say i mean but he has a very tough
fight with uh with cereal guys so so let
me let me go back to the questions i was
trying to get to a point there the
question was what do you what do you
think about what's going on right now
between jake and dana
um you know uh
jake is being jake you know jake brings
up a lot of good points but at the same
time you know um
it's a different ball game you know what
i'm saying with mixed martial arts um
there there are some things that uh you
know does need to get better with mixed
martial arts when it comes for you know
uh advocating rights for for fighters
and things like that but
um i think the ufc has done a very good
job of where they came from and where
they get into right now you know
we forget that all these other sports
you know they've had a long time to get
to where they are right now you know
baseball football the big three and it
just takes time you know the ufc is
moving in a progressive manner i don't
believe that the ufc holds their
fighters down i think that you know they
they uh they take care of the fighters
um you know could could fighters pay be
better yeah i think so you know but at
the end of the day um there are fighters
who make you know crazy bank you know
fighting with the ufc and um you know
when it comes to
the the pay that's even distributed
between the the non you know non big
name fighters i think that that's very
comparable to to boxing and other
leagues like that too you know you know
gerard made a very good point yesterday
who he got me thinking
if you know how they say uh
uh people get paid more paid in boxing
uh than they do in ufc right okay so i
pulled it up i'm like let me see this
here
top ten highest paid boxers okay i don't
know what it is joseph parker is number
10 okay highest paid boxer
and
blah blah blah blah blah blah let's see
he made
three million dollars okay guaranteed
purse 2018 he made 10 million dollars
okay last year yeah i mean then it's
michael hunter
who has an estimated net worth of three
million dollars he's the ninth highest
paid boxer in the world in 2021 okay so
the ninth highest guy
made three million
then you got the next guy then you got
the next guy next guy and it goes all
the way up to the top anthony joshua who
made
a 125 million dollars in 2018 and he got
a big offer for what he's going to get
paid he tyson fury's not even first
place he's second place wilder is third
place right and then you got some of
these other guys
canelo's gotta be number one well canelo
is number one but you look at somebody's
list here canelo's what 360 or whatever
they're paying that guy 20
20 22. let's look at the number here if
you can pull up 2022
highest paid boxers i'm actually very
curious if you match the two up
i'm willing to bet the highest paid ufc
fighter makes more money than the
highest paid
boxer right if you if you match the two
so there there is an argument and then
the other part is the following
is are there more ufc fights than actual
boxing fights that we watch on tv 100
there's more ufc fights and here's
another thing the fact that you know if
i'm a fighter and i'm getting paid a
certain amount yeah i can put in my
contract i want this amount to be
disclosed
and then i can and then i can have the
ufc pay me uh whatever else outside of
that you know what i'm saying so i don't
i don't i don't have to have all of my
money being disclosed explain that why
like every nba contract mlb contract nfl
contract is pretty much disclosed why in
the ufc is there so non-disclosure so
the ufc they pay the commission and the
commission pays the fighters right so i
can have the ufc say that i make this
amount of money and have them pay me
that and give the commission that but i
can actually be getting paid a little
bit more on the back end you know uh
and and just in just another way you
know what's the back end way what is
that so the back end way would be like
so i say say my contract was for like uh
um three million dollars say okay i want
um a million dollars to be shown but
then pay me the other two million
dollars give that to tom go ahead pay me
the other two million dollars just
through the ufc you know so they so that
that can happen you know so you don't
always have to have all your money being
shown the munchkin yeah tom can you do
me a favor you know to me
businesses get criticism for
uh how they run a certain model can you
find out what is a ufc's ebitda like
what's their margin like if they do
i don't know four billion dollars do
they keep forty percent do they keep ten
percent did they keep twenty percent if
you can pull up that number because this
is why we got the biz doc yeah no no i
think that's very important because
business gotta run a margin and you
gotta have you know the number is around
twenty percent if ufc like you know how
some of these software companies you'll
talk to yeah we've consulted quite a few
of them they'll have a software and
they'll do 10 million a year but it's a
software i'm just giving you the
software so i don't need to really do
anything else and their margins are 60
right yeah you got a lot of money you
can maybe pay your engineers better but
if you're running a business with
operation setup this this that and your
margins are only 20
a business has got to make their 20 so
meaning whatever dana and those guys
have done has worked and it's made a lot
of people rich
can they improve in certain ways if they
could what would you say would be a way
they could improve it jake made his
proposal saying take the twelve thousand
fifty thousand you know health benefits
etc etc what would you say as a ufc hall
of famer yeah i mean um
health benefits would be one but i mean
i would i would also say uh you know
some kind of um
portion of the money for the retirement
you know what i'm saying for fighters
who who who who are done fighting you
know sort of 401k an ira profit sheriff
okay so so say for instance this like um
like
you know
if if i'm a fighter and i get paid for a
pay-per-view i should get paid
any time that that fight is being shown
even after i'm retired you know what i'm
saying and i feel like that's that could
make it better like for instance like
any time the show was shot evans fight i
should be is that how this unboxing does
boxing do that or
no i don't i don't think i don't think
boxing does it like that but i'm saying
that's something that could help that's
something that could help out because
they're still getting money to pay like
the ufc is getting money to you
know to licenses
they're making some money yes so they're
making money so if they're making money
on sean and rashad evans fight yeah then
rashad admits you get paid off of it
yeah i'm saying even if i'm not fighting
a current fighter ufc when i was in la i
was uh
handling finances for a few nfl players
and they would all complain about
retirement and i would say hey they
don't pay this they don't pay they don't
pay enough right uh and then but at the
same time it was hey
you know i always watch how you take
care of your champions okay you can't
take care of everybody but how you take
care of your champions for example like
you know how
uh
people can say whatever they want to say
about mark cuban and who he is he takes
care of his best guys look at dirk he's
been taking care of for 20 years turk's
like i can go a lot of different places
miss i love my boss i'll work over here
the guy gives me what he wants so he
takes care of him right
do you do you think ufc takes care of
their champions like not everybody
because i can see how that can be
watered down and this guy's saying give
me this and that guy's saying give me
this but there is a system for guys who
were champions right do they do that is
there benefits for you guys yeah
absolutely i mean you know
if i call dana and ask him for anything
you know he'd be like yeah absolutely he
seems like that yeah yeah he he's that
guy dana's dana's um you know he has a
kind of persona out you know when you
see him on camera but you know dana's
one of the coolest guys you ever meet
and he's and he's straight up you know
what i'm saying like you may not like
what he says but you're going to know
that he's speaking from the heart you
know what i'm saying you're going to
know where you stand with them and i can
always handle that you know what i'm
saying i don't always got to like what
somebody say but if they kind of you
know shooting straight from the hips
then i can accept that and dana's one of
those guys so um and and you know he
does take care of his champions you know
he um he makes sure that he does
whatever he can you know he's he's one
of those guys who
who does things and doesn't say anything
about it like people doesn't people
don't really know how generous dana is
and the things that he do do because he
doesn't he's not one of those guys say
oh i did this and he doesn't brag about
it at all he just does it so so would
you say behind close like francis said
the other day he had a private meeting
with dana and he said what a great
conversation he had with him like he was
very
uh uh positive about the conversation
would you say behind closed doors
champions
love dana and have a great relationship
with dana absolutely okay i think that
that's that's the i think that right
there finishes the conversation if you
ask me is dana white the greatest
commissioner in the history of sports
you've had david stern in the nba paul
tagliabue nfl good dell
uh would you count vince mcmahon
vince mcmahon okay but is dana white i
would be probably on the promoter's side
mm-hmm yeah that would be
you know is he i was i would say uh he's
definitely up there you know when it
comes to um
just being the guy who's you know able
to relate on so many different levels
you know that's that's what dana does
dana can uh come at you from a different
perspective and he can understand where
you're coming from and he doesn't uh he
doesn't big time you you know and that's
and that's that's that's a huge thing
because you know sometimes when you
don't have the same value that they can
get out of you people have the tendency
to kind of dismiss you but dana dana
doesn't do that and that's one thing
that you know um
i can say that you know stands
high in his you know in in his character
and who he is as a person because he
always makes sure to you know
yeah he'll return a text you know no
matter how busy he is he'll return the
text he'll return a call so you know
he's one of those guys
you know what i'm really impressed by
the wide perspective you take on the
sport here you're talking about
you're talking about the leader of the
sport talk about the sport itself you're
talking about guys you fought you know
there was a time when peyton manning
they said hey the nfl is peyton's league
remember that and it was because
owners trusted him by and large but he
also influenced the competition
committee he influenced rules committee
definitely did a lot for the players
association yeah i got it right here
okay and um
it was it was really tremendous and he
used that platform to really help and i
think he's really proud of that you
sound like you really take a broad
perspective your your record as a
fighter is there 2008 is legendary right
and everything that you did that year
what do you want like the young fighters
and people that look to you to see your
impact in the sport that maybe was
beyond the octagon where you used your
your platform there to help the sport
um well uh i've been trying to do you
know a few things you know uh you know
for one i started a team and i've had
some fighters who i've developed and
they become champion like camaro oozeman
and you know you're a guy yeah that was
my guy you know um number one right now
he's ranked yeah 2022. absolutely and
you know i started a whole movement
whole team you know a big team has grown
you know because of me even moving here
to south florida and starting the flag
you were part of black zillions yeah huh
you started black zone i started black
zones yeah yeah it was me uh jazias uh
yuri villaford and um and uh bigfoot and
a few other guys um so we we we started
the black zillions and it grew to be one
of the biggest teams and you know
compete with it it was kind of the nwo
for a little bit it was like it was it
was like the new world order taken over
there for a little bit and then the
black zillions and uh you guys had the
whole uh actually it was more like the
generation x if you're a wrestling fan
like you guys you guys came in and you
guys were were the with the out you guys
were the underdogs and the outcasts and
it did it took off and then uh the black
zillions the uh the owner did it was the
did the owner pass away
the owner uh passed away glenn robinson
passed away and you know it transitioned
to sanford mma so that's what it is now
for mma but um and it was american top
team uh you guys were competitors with
american top team correct yeah we went
against the american top team in the
ultimate fighter show and we beat them
in the ultimate fighter show so i mean
that's that's pretty you know pretty
high praise because of the fact that
american top teams been around for so
long and they've you know they're
they're at another level when it comes
to their training facility and the
athletes they come out of the gym
so i mean it's it was very you know very
good to be able to show that what we
could do in just a short amount of time
that we did it but that'd be a great
espn 30 for 30 to black zillions man
you guys had it had a wild run there for
a little bit absolutely but i mean you
know to answer your question you know um
trevor whitman and myself trevor is uh
the designer of this you know equipment
company called onyx because when you
look at the sport you know there's
things in it that you know uh you know
you want to make safer you know you
always see about the gloves and eye
pokes and things like that and you know
some of these injuries that happen you
know 70 of the injuries they happen
outside of training and that usually is
due to the fact that you know unlike any
other sport when you know when it comes
to football or uh you know um
hockey or whatever when it comes to
these uh contact sports you know every
single year
their equipment is being improved you
know but when it comes to
combat sports you know the the boxing
glove hasn't been improved since they
attached the thumb to it and you know
with mma you know the glove hasn't
really been improved since they uh
opened the straps up so it's easier to
put a glove on but um we wanted to do
and trevor whitman is is the you know
the genius behind this you know he
designed a whole glove that made it so
that you know it's really hard and
almost impossible to poke somebody in
the eye but more importantly it offers
the perfect support you know he had the
system and a glove that offered the
perfect support and he had a whole list
of gear that was like that you know when
it comes to shin guards knee guards and
just a whole
equipment line that he designed and
behind it and that's what we want to uh
bring into the ufc and you know because
it's about you know we love to fight and
fight is a fight doing anything but in
anything but at the end of the day you
we have to remember that there's life
outside of fighting and you want to be
able to
be able to you know walk and do the
things that you like to do once you get
done fighting so you know being able to
uh
build up the equipment help out these
athletes in that perspective is
something that we were trying to do
you think francis you think francis has
an argument
you think francis has an argument on
saying i'm not never going to fight for
500 000 or 600 thousand anymore because
here's what the article says
it says neganu
details comma with dana white clarifies
contracts by the way he tom just pulled
up the ebitda which was emailed to tyler
in a moment tom if you can explain to us
what that means we'll go through that
here in a minute but
uh nagano has revealed what was said in
a recent conversation with dan white and
also clarifies his contract status and
ufc if he defeats uh cyril uh gain next
weekend speaking with you espn thursday
nagano shared more intimate details of
their conversation and went pretty well
at this point i'm not upset i'm kind of
chill about everything and i went to him
we wish every each other happy holidays
and i tell them my frustration i
expressed to him how i would like to
stay with the ufc but i don't feel like
ufc still wants me to stay so i don't
feel promoted anymore i mean maybe i'm
wrong with about that and i don't see
anything compared to what happened to
different fighters when i asked dana uh
white in response to his observation
danis uh nagano praised the ufc boss for
being quick on his feet he bring up
uh something really fast and that's why
you know that dana white is very good he
tells me like yeah we want you have you
ever wanted to go somewhere and we
didn't take care of you i'm like yeah
but i think it's more than that anyways
they went back and forth all this i've
had this contract since 24 2017 and i
think you know the 500 600 000
to nagano him getting paid 500 600 you
think he's getting underpaid you think
he's getting paid the right amount who's
got the better argument because i got a
follow-up to that for you
uh he should definitely get paid
um over 600 000
because when you look at his his value
when it comes to um if he wasn't in ufc
right say you know they walked and he
went their separate ways
he can do a boxing match with you know
uh
um
tyson fury tyson fury uh you know
deontay walder and get paid millions and
millions of dollars do you think dana
cares
yes i think dana gears
meaning you think
you think dana cares
that deant that he could go and fight
one of those guys make five to ten
million to the point where he'd be
willing to match that pay to keep him
there
he he knows his value he knows what he
has in in gano okay and he knows that um
but do you know what i'm asking like
yeah you know like for example i
remember one time shaq went to
pat riley and he says listen man you
know
miami heat you know 20 million a year
and he called jerry bus he says jerry
you know it's me or kobe man miami wants
to give me 20 million you know what
jerry told him he said take it
he said because i'm not going to pay 20
million
i said go take you go get your money so
when he got his 20 million dollars
because shaq was at his end of his uh
right career second dude i'm not gonna
pay 20 million and jerry banked on
uh what do you call it uh kobe at the
time rather than paying uh shaq but in
this case isn't francis like at his peak
like isn't he like at a he's still got a
few more years where he can go like this
right he can sell out arena sell out
pay-per-view absolutely and here's the
thing about it like when you look at a
heavyweight that can do what francis
does
it's it just makes the whole league look
better because you know
there can be a lot of great fighters in
other different weight classes but
heavyweight just says something you know
the baddest man in the world has to be a
heavyweight it just kind of like it just
seems like that's just the right thing
to be right you know uh no matter how
good somebody is at 155 you're like yeah
he's tough but i mean i probably can
whoop his ass you know what i'm saying
like nagano would whoop conor mcgregor's
ass right i mean that's just but there's
no there's no doubt when you see francis
fight and you see him punch somebody
that you know that he'll probably knock
your head off into a stratosphere you
know there's that fear factor so
having a heavyweight that can do what
francis does is is not you know not
something that you just want to let go
and that's something that you value uh
somebody who can close out the show
somebody who's going to bring you so
here's my follow-up to that and this is
this is where i'm curious to know what
you would say about this because you
know so you got a uh francis who is
a great fighter
but he's not a promoter so he's not a
guy that's going to go out there and
promote like let's just say conor will
promote right a massive adult will
promote a kobe will promote usman is not
even a promoter usman's a great fighter
but is not a
like
you know people who want to watch usman
fight is because they want to see this
guy see if somebody can take him down
they're not going to because he's a
great promoter he's doing this he's not
that guy he just comes shows up does his
job and matter of fact i don't even
think promoting is natural to him right
i think it's natural to certain people
do you think to dana dana's
dana's a guy to build as the face of ufc
is more somebody that's also great
personality promoter rather than
somebody that just shows up and fights
yeah i mean i think there's a balance
there you know what i'm saying i think
that you know in certain fighters
everybody can't be the same you know if
everybody was the same and everybody
went out there and they talked trash and
they you know try to zealous thing to
become very monotonous and boring at the
same time because everybody's given the
same thing but there's a subtle
confidence in francis and there's just
this
i wonder what's going to happen when he
connects you know like this week this
fight is coming up this weekend you know
he's francis isn't saying much but at
the same time the anticipation for it is
very high you know you have serial gun
in there and you have francis and ghana
these guys are training partners you
know france's old training partner is
now serial gun trainer partner and then
there's this whole history about you
know francis may have knocked him out in
training practice and whatnot so
there's an anticipation and there's many
different ways to sell a fight you know
if if i'm a promoter i understand who
i'm promoting you know sometimes guys
need a less of a push than other guys
the guys who need more push then that's
when you have to start being a better
promoter and get the people that want to
see him yeah and also you've got guys
like khabib you've got guys like george
st pierre some of the biggest fighters
of all time don't have to go out there
and act like clowns it's not the wwe
some of those guys that aren't the great
fighters that kind of know a little bit
this is my moment i better get the most
out of it those are the guys that go out
there and and then you have like a
connor who's probably better on the mic
than he is in the ring so i mean yeah
you you have something with inganu
that there's if he has any card to play
with dana it's the fact that dana i
think anyway
has been waiting patiently for the mega
fight of the decade he's been waiting
two years for jon jones to get his
weight up and he wants to ngano jon
jones fight so i don't think he's going
to let him know donald john jar they
even in the same weight class
they are john jon jones has gotten to be
a heavyweight and he's big
and he's you know he's got that that
light light heavyweight mentality
meaning the fact that he can fight in
many different ways he can wrestle he
can do just who would be favored in that
fight
i mean
you're talking about arguably the number
one ufc fighter in history
i think the question is ring rust a real
thing is ring rust a real thing
yeah ring rust is a real thing it is a
real thing and um but it also depends on
like who you are as a fighter you know
what i'm saying sometimes people go out
there and they exhibit that kind of ring
rust but i mean when you're out for so
long
uh the game changes like that in subtle
ways that um if you're not in there you
don't you don't you don't even realize
because there's so much that goes into
being able to fight you know it's a it's
more mental than it is physical when it
gets down to you know fight week and
being in the cage on fight day so you
have to be able to uh
you know bring yourself there a little
bit every single day and stay on top of
the mental game if you don't stay on top
of the mental game then when you get out
there you can go out there and
experience some ring rust so you think
somebody like jon jones even one of
maybe the single best fighter of all
time
two years out of the ring he's going to
get that adrenaline dump the ring rust
and then you have somebody like ingano
in there
it's recipe for disaster do you think
jon jones is just so good jon jones is
so good but here there's something
different about jon jones like jon jones
uh one thing that i really like about
jon jones and i hold high praises for
him four is because of the fact that you
know his life could be falling apart
around
uh a fight but yet when he's in the cage
he's laser and focus and he's locked in
that right there is a talent that a lot
of people can't can't do you know for me
i had a hard time juggling life outside
and then getting inside the cage and not
letting it affect my performance so
being able to do that is an art form in
itself and jon jones has been able to
you know he's exhibited that time and
time again so it's hard to say if jon
jones is going to go and fall for it and
you know go and have the ring rust that
you would anticipate anybody else being
out as long as he
do you think we'll win if these guys
face each other
man
it's a tough one to call to be honest
and i'm not just trying to say that to
try to give a 50 50 answer but
you know you have francis who is you
know has been a sponge you know
training with francis and seeing
france's growth from the time he started
to where he is now it's hard to say that
he can't do all those things that a
mixed martial artist fighters can do you
know before it was like only he only had
the big power well now he can grapple
now he can wrestle now he can defend
takedowns now he has a better
understanding of where the fight needs
to be and how to get a guy to in his
fight you know and then you have jon
jones at the aspect you know who
understands a great flow of a fight has
great defense and at the same time he's
just very smart inside the cage so it's
a very tough one to call but i mean
here's here's the thing that i think
about when i think about this matchup is
that you know when jon jones was at you
know 205 his last few fights he was
getting caught with some punches you
know and it was making him look a little
bit more human so i would say if he goes
up the heavyweight and he doesn't patch
up those holes then he can get caught
with a big shot and and
peak
of jon jones
versus francis is it even if i'm talking
peak peak when john was peaking where
you you were in the ring with these
people yeah yeah
john jones is something special when
you're speaking i mean
to to fight to fight how jon jones used
to fight and back then it was just it
was ridiculous because he was so um he
was so creative inside the octagon and
he had no fear
so when you don't have any fear and you
have that creativity you're looking at
somebody who was just absolutely dynamic
and then his athleticism and his range
and everything else that he had so i
would say jon jones you know um you know
people's you know they don't want to
give jon jones credit because of the
things that he's done and things like
that but you know when you look at the
talent just of what he's been able to do
i mean you just you got to give it to
him because
he's he's working with a different set
of skills when it comes to
i was using his elbow as a jab like well
that's his only loss what do you see
he's only lost that elbow to the
forehead right i mean yeah where they
stopped him he's like oh my gosh i
didn't know you can't do this it was
just like natural to him
but but who's your top five if you're so
you know you give your top five when the
conversation comes up you know in every
sport there's that convo who do you put
as an all-time great and by the way not
by weight class just go go oh
i will say jon jones number one i'll say
uh
um
habib gotta go
number two okay i would say uh
gsp
you better you put a b above
esp yeah
and then i'll say um
camaro oozeman four and i'll say
anderson silva
you put silver fifth yeah there was a
time also silva was vicious just nasty
when he would fight yeah i mean that
these are guys that i like to fight i
mean i love i love the way habit fight
you know and i think that you know um
gsp is amazing too gsp has been my
training partner for years and just
absolutely amazing when it comes to
fighting and this fight iq was just on
another level who's he missing pat
there's someone on your top five you
know i i listen this is his world
did you watch this gerard i do listen
the average person may who doesn't know
the sport technically is gonna say
obviously how about conor mcgregor not
be in the top five uh but but to put
those names
these guys went on a streak all of those
guys went on a streak of 20 matches
maybe i'm mistaken i think it's all of
them have gone
20 plus undefeated right yeah obviously
jon jones the only losses the one that
he had no clue what was going on he
started elbowing on the guy number two
you said khabib who was what 30 28 i
know or i don't know is it 29 29 no okay
so that's that guy
three you put gsp who he went on a
rampage for a while
for you said usman who right now is
undefeated isn't it
how many how many matches has he what is
a usman's record today i couldn't even
tell he's 19. 19 and no pull it up so
yeah i mean
usman is usman and then he got five
being silver silva who went for a while
as well so give an honorable mention
yeah who who's not on the list
he's very very he's very company biased
here he's got nobody from pride fader
doesn't get any any love
we got nothing for uh for any of the
gracies we got nothing i mean i mean i'm
thinking about you know he doesn't want
his friends to get mad at him i can say
you know i can say i can say an
honorable mention i can say fedor is
definitely in it i forgot all about
fedor see i forgot about fedor man i
forgot about fatal fate fedor it can
definitely be in the top five that's got
to be
dana white's biggest mistake right that
that that's got to be his biggest regret
you figured yeah i mean fedor not
getting them
over a t-shirt
tell the story well well the story as i
understand it is vader has his own uh
his own clothing line and he wanted to
promote his own clothing line when he
came to the to tyler pull up this guy
uh and dana ring dana has a reebok deal
you gotta wear reebok and that's that's
but is that is that on dana or is that a
ufc deal they just could never come come
to they can never come together on on
the uh on the sponsorship i wonder
i wonder if it's the sport now but fedor
man fedor 20 years ago i mean
they're fighting him and randall man you
can watch that on repeat and you'll
never get tired of it
i mean yeah some of the old school guys
too and then the rules were so different
the guys had to fight five times in a
night you can get five times in a night
grand priest let me ask a different
question let me ask a different question
so we just right now i said fight
fighters right
you know jon jones khabib gsp usman and
at the bottom silva
top five
greatest promoters
who were also good fighters we don't
even need to talk about number one it's
really who number two is because number
one is obviously yeah do you put anybody
above him muhammad ali no no i'm saying
connor they're working in their world do
you put anybody ahead of connor as the
greatest promoter who was a fighter talk
talker
you know um troll all of that nobody's
greater than connor i mean i would say
uh number two will be uh chael sonnen
okay
number two
uh let's see what will be number three
um
the diaz brothers
ah man yeah they they're very good at
selling i mean but they don't even they
don't even mean to sell it they just
themselves unapologetic unapologetically
yeah so you put them three both of them
i would say so yeah i mean those guys
those guys can sell a fight i mean uh
let's see who else is on there you think
kobe's a good promoter kobe kobe
covington is a great promoter he's a
good promoter uh who who else are we
missing a name like i'm trying to
see he said anderson silva and this is
what i always loved about the spider the
spider barely spoke english but he was
such a performer inside the ring
he was he dude he was promoting his next
fight while he was beating the opponent
like he was you know and you know until
uh what's his name from long island
caught him
uh like that's what you were saying you
do it for so long you do it for so long
and all it takes is well chris weidman
one time yeah wait a minute on this
story with son and then i want to go to
yours is the press conference with sonan
and uh in uh uh
in silva where he says look all you guys
are talking about english look if i go
to brazil there's an app to learn how to
speak brazilian this guy is not
traveling here from brazil he lives in
vegas and he flies to he lives in
beverly hills and he flies to vegas i'm
traveling all the way i should feel
sorry for me not for this guy he was a
great smack talker he was he brought it
he was phenomenal man i mean he he would
practice his lines and he would just get
it down to the point where i mean he was
just so fluid with it you know and he
just you know he unlocked his talent i
think he's one of the big reasons to
help you know kobe covington kind of
come into his own and just you know be
the phenomenal promoter kobe is i mean
kobe is
kobe's up there you know kobe's really
good kobe says some stuff that
you know he's kind of funny you know
what i'm saying he's kind of funny the
things that he says and i think that
i think that's what that's what it has
to be you know you have to you know be
quick with it but at the same time kind
of funny at the same time the fight
world needs a heal for sure yeah for
sure who's kobe fighting coming up
who's favorite in that kobe for sure for
sure for sure you you said something
very interesting you said practices
lines are you telling me that dana and
the ufc are having guys uh they're
giving guys some help with what they
should say and
leading up to the fights nah these guys
these guys do it on their own it's 100
organic 100 the beef is 100 percent
organic 100 it's not you know mayweather
and mcgregor talking smack to each other
and then going back and into the room
after the press isn't there i mean like
good one old chap we're just selling
something
when the beef is because with mma we
still have that like that bushido code
you know where we just kind of like
honor and respect and then when somebody
disrespects you
it it cuts at a different level you know
so you can't just shake it off and it's
not like nah we're not friends until i
punch you in the face you know
and then after you're not friends until
i punch you yeah and then after we punch
each other in the face a few times she's
gonna fight we are not friends
here's my question for you bro and
here's what i want you to do here all
right leave your humbleness at the door
for one second we're throwing all these
names out there okay
gsp connor promoting kobe usman you're a
freaking hall of famer bro
lose the humbleness where are you at on
this list like what like give me a
little like i'll tell you what mother
give me something where are you at
that's not me man i know i don't i don't
i don't i don't feel like i i need to uh
to do that you know i feel like um
you know
i am who i am you know and what i did
but if you had to rank yourself in this
top five top ten you're not i wouldn't
win i wouldn't even wreck my straight up
no i wouldn't do it better question
rashad could adam last an entire minute
in the ring with you not even wonderful
let's talk about john jones let's talk
about jon jones and greg jackson because
uh you know
you for the stories you were talking
about with greg jackson on on mental
toughness like some of the stuff is
psychotic like when you were saying on
joe rogan you carry your guy in and you
have to be willing to die you know for
your buddies and to go through this
when when john came through you're the
older brother to him right you were
playing because you were the guy that
ran the camp and you made the camp
popular everybody knew you were that
name right and in this world camps are
very important right
great coach gets a great player that
player can also make the coach very
famous in sports college tim duncan made
pop pretty famous michael made
feel very famous kobe didn't really make
feel famous because phil was already
famous but michael made feels famous
right
how how was john's energy when he came
in because i've heard what you've said
about him before
and i you know the interview you guys
did together with it wasn't joe was
somebody else interviewing the two of
you guys before the fight you know what
i'm talking about and then i've seen
daniel cormier and him talk and what
daniel says about john where he says
he'll never change you don't make
mistakes over and over and over again
etc etc you you hear that whole
conversation with joe was i think
hosting that interview
who was
john when he first walked into the camp
who was that guy
he was an eager student you know john
just wanted to learn um
very big imagination you know uh he
would he would uh you know after
training he'd be one of those guys who
would just sit and just you know uh play
around and kind of just uh you know try
out different moves like just you know
like these different um
you know conceptual moves you know
things that you may never pull off but
he'll do those things over and over
again things that people wouldn't expect
a very big imagination um very eager to
uh to be the guy you know i remember we
went out one time and he's like oh man
what is it like to have you know people
come up to you and want to take pictures
and i'm like one day you'll find out you
know you know it's so super ambitious
very ambitious curious was he humble um
yeah he was humble he was confident but
confident very confident so he had
swagger even coming in oh yeah he he
wanted he wanted he wanted to be um he
wanted to be the guy and he knew he one
day he would be how old was he when you
first met him
maybe 21 maybe 21. and so when you guys
were sparring did you
when you're practicing did you say
this guy's different like did you
immediately feel that this guy is
different than everybody else yeah yeah
i remember um we were doing we're doing
uh we're doing
wrestling we're doing wrestling i used
to take everybody down
and uh and i went with him for the first
time and i'm like all right i'll go and
he took me down and i was like first
time first time and i was like oh yeah
i mean he's been wrestling his brothers
his whole life two nfl players
and he's the skinniest in the family so
he was 6'4 170 in junior year yeah he's
got he's got a freaky dimension that
kind of adds to you know his athleticism
and what he's able to do in the octagon
was he was he a troublemaker before or
did he pick up the habits after all the
attention came
um you know i i would say that you know
john is uh i wouldn't say a troublemaker
i'll just say that he would um
what gets john in trouble is because
every four four weeks before his fight
he he likes to blow off a little bit of
steam and it's kind of like his ritual
that he does where you know he wants to
um
you know it's like a little celebration
to himself you know and it's kind of
like his thing where you know he'll go
and he'll party like four weeks before
he fights and then he uh finished the
rest of his camp
you know but when he goes he goes hard
you know what i'm saying he goes hard in
the paint yeah but blow off a little
literally a little too literally yeah a
little too literally but was that like
was it what i'm trying to find out is
like you know sometimes i i interviewed
billy bean we had him at the event billy
bean i don't know if you've seen a movie
money ball with uh uh brad pitt you know
the baseball movie if you've seen it and
i said billy you're a recruiter when
you're recruiting guys what are you
looking for he says
obviously talent
okay physical like what you what you
look like physically you take care of
yourself and then he said uh a work
ethic and then he said up ringgit
and upbringing is if we don't have that
that's tough because eventually
this guy's going to mess up his career
that's what he would say so they would
look at a lot of stars like for himself
he was coming up they thought he was
going to be a big star and you know mlb
all-star play very quickly they realized
you're good for ml you're good for
triple a you're good for college but
you're gonna make it in the he says i
knew very quickly i don't belong in this
league john knew he belonged in the
league but
i wonder like you know sometimes you're
hanging out and i remember being in the
army
one weekend these guys are like we're
gonna go and party at this place i just
got this gut feeling i'm like dude i'm
just not gonna go with these guys i'm
just not getting a good feeling about
these guys going where they're going so
i didn't go that weekend everybody got
arrested everybody went to jail
everybody was dishonorably discharged
that one weekend so is it
the dna in him
is it he learned it from somebody is it
the friends is it the coach
who where do you play it's in him okay
he's got he's got that wild side to him
you know there's a part see see the same
things that make you great
in one area will make you not so great
in the other area you know what i'm
saying and the fact that you know he
takes risks in a cage and he he lives
like that you know he he he takes risk
in his life too you know and um it's uh
it's part of
it's part of who he is you know i think
there are some things that he needs to
sort out within himself you know and i
feel that he's he's he's doing those
things but you know
being able to do those things and being
able to confront a very uh ugly side of
yourself is confronting it you know what
i'm saying and being open and honest
about it to the point where you know
you're willing to deal with it and i
feel like he still needs to make strides
in that area you know being accountable
for the things that that actually you
know keep bringing him back to that
place and i feel like
as he grows even more you know because
he's not the same kid he was when he's
making no mistakes he's still making
those mistakes because he wasn't
accountable for it because he was 34 now
i mean yeah different ball game it's a
different ball game and here and here's
the sad thing and here's what i do not
want for him i do not want him to still
be making those mistakes
once there's no value in him anymore
once people don't you know can't get
another penny out of it because at that
point
then you go down a whole different
spiral different spiral you know and
that's what i i don't hope for i hope
that he um
he figures it out because there's
something in him that's causing him to
keep going back to that place and he is
the only person that can sort that out
does does he does he have guys like you
in his ears like you guys you sound like
a lot of a lot different relationship
today than the way you guys were
speaking eight years ago yeah you know
what i'm saying you sound and the way
you're speaking about him so have you
guys mended have you guys spoken have
you guys hung out have you guys broken
bread have you guys gone to dinner is
there that relationship again um we
don't have that relationship but you
know whenever i see him i speak to him
and say what's up to him you know give
him some well wishes and things like
that you know i'm nothing but love for
the guy you know um
you know uh you know there's a couple
times i had some dreams about i'm like
oh man i gotta check on john so i'll
call his manager malkie and like hey is
john okay i just had this crazy dream
that you know this happened to him you
know chuckling make sure that he's good
you know because
you know i i i care about the kid you
know what i'm saying
and i don't want him to
uh i want him to be
the guy that he can be i want him to be
that guy
you ever uh uh
like even coming up you know in the in
the world of business i've been around a
lot of guys that were 10 times better
than me in insurance right
but you'd sit there and you talk i'd
watch like we're in a room say somebody
that's doing very well for themselves
they're giving counsel to us right
i'd watch
the other guys that i was in the same
camp with so imagine like an ultimate
fight or whatever but we're in an
ultimate fighter but for insurance
business right
and one of the guys in the room just
looked at everybody like with the smirk
on his face like dude i'm 10 times
better than all you guys you guys have
no clue what you're talking about i know
what i'm you could never give this
person counsel and god forbid if you did
the level of sensitivity to the roof
oh my gosh you like get uncomfortable
like you know you know what i'm talking
about
there's no way a guy gets that good
without having taken coaching from
somebody
do you know what i'm saying like there's
no way you're born with those abilities
so he must have the ability to take the
coaching
in areas that he wants to
but the other side where you know a
cormier says he'll never change do you
agree with cormier that he'll never
change certain things
um
i don't agree with that you know i think
that uh i think that people can change
all the time and i feel like it just
takes the right situation to to make
that change happen you know um i'm not
the person who i was ten years ago in so
many different aspects not even five
years ago you know i've changed in so
many different ways and and that change
happened within me but it took me
realizing it you know no one could make
me change it was something that i needed
to see for myself to have that change
happen and you never know what happens
in life you know life can pull you in a
different you know direction and you
know uh have you see something that you
didn't see before and then you change as
a person
yeah listen this is coming from a fan
you know you you know from a fan
perspective you want to see this guy
figure it out because the guy is he he's
got he's got michael in them
but he's got rodman in him so very weird
i'm a strong guy
he's got a strawberry and maybe a little
dwight good and you can but you can ask
him a question yes right now basically
what you're talking about is growing up
and personal growth okay and pat
let off the entire conversation with who
you were when you were age 22 versus now
you're 42.
so
you you did a hot boxing with mike tyson
and i mean the first half hour you were
talking about things that you used to do
and things that you're doing now so my
question revolves around personal growth
you're now a vegan
you used to say you know you eat meat
whatever
you used to party smoke drink whatever
that you know that kind of lifestyle now
you're doing mushrooms you have your
meta toad yeah um you know you talked
about dmt i've done dmt that shit's wild
i've done some mushrooms uh mom hope
you're not listening
um
but my question is like you've grown up
clearly you've got like you got it going
on bro like you you're you're like the
the the you're knocking people out in
the ring but here just like you're
very chill casual dude the personal
growth
when did you have to grow up
um and what did like what you're doing
now with your because your company is it
meditate is that what it is yeah
meditation just explain the personal
growth and where you're at even with
your diet your health your exercise your
mentality your emotions things that
you're putting in your body where's that
all at um you know i i felt like i
needed to grow up and just you know when
i just kept bumping my head you know and
just having things setbacks happen to me
and just trying to figure out like where
where it was coming from you know and
how i was my own worst enemy and how i
kept on causing myself to re have these
same repeating patterns in my life
and um you know facing a lot of part of
my
a lot of the part of myself that i
didn't want to face before you know and
you know i um i point to psychedelics
not because i'm like everybody needs to
you know use psychedelics in order to
get to
to find truth but
um
using psychedelics allow me to get
perspective you know
the only thing that can help you get
perspective without it is time you know
but sometimes you don't have time you
know and um
being able to get the perspective that i
have when i was you know using
psychedelics allowed me to see areas in
myself that i was you know i needed to
change in areas i needed to confront and
and those you know was was a spawn of
you know that was the spawn of me you
know changing and wanting to do better
for myself and uh you know doing you
know doing better for people that are
affected you know by being a certain
kind of way and um
that was only something that
only i could do for myself there was
only something that i i had to see for
myself but you know i wasn't able to see
for myself because i was caught in that
habitual pattern of just doing the same
thing and not being able to see you know
uh where i was coming up short and so uh
it's been it's been a different uh
different path for me and that's why
even when i even came back to fighting
you know just
just because i want to feel it from this
perspective you know i fought from one
perspective for the longest time but i
never fought you know in this
perspective and i wanted to just you
know have that and experience that
because you know i've um i've grown so
much in this area where i just wanted to
see what it would be like now
it's it's hard to fight from a from a
place of of
you know
confidence like that from your in
yourself so much of fighting comes from
self-hatred and self-loathing and you
know externalizing a lot of the things
that that you know you've internalized
your whole life so now when you find
peace
is there any fear that you won't have
that same rage you won't be able to
unleash that that same you know get
yourself into that same you know violent
primordial being you need to be to face
another man like that um that's a good
question i feel like that's um
one of the things that kind of
uh led to me not fighting the way i felt
like i needed to fight in the last few
fights because you know i found peace in
a lot of different areas where um i was
struggling before you know uh you know
fighting has been therapy for me to be
honest you know and some of the things
that i was working through in life i
found a way to work through them through
fighting but um
now as a fighter and and where i'm at
right now
i don't feel like i need to be
angry or have the the feelings of of
that that dog you know um
in that kind of way you know now i know
how to
how to hit a switch and mentally bring
myself to that point and you know
unleash that beast and be savage when i
need to be and at the same time you know
be another way when i need to be it's
not just you i mean you know you look at
guys in the nfl they don't know that at
the end of their career they can turn it
off or even in the offseason they can't
turn it off yeah you look at dudes that
are fighting you look at soldiers that
come back i mean when you're and it's
not necessarily their fault when you're
trained to be a hammer all you're gonna
see is nails right you know so i mean
in that regard i mean it's it's a really
interesting you're almost like a case
study you're a case study for for you
know professionally violent people yeah
to see if they can kind of turn it on
turn it off and if it can be controlled
violence or if that just kind of takes
over your personality yeah i mean it's
uh it's a very uh interesting
process to be honest because you know
you
you have this mindset where you know you
are
a fighter
and you know when you
engage that beast enough times it just
becomes who you are on so many different
levels so then when you don't have it
anymore you have to find a new way to
uh let it out you know without letting
it out in an uncontrolled manner that is
not acceptable anymore because you know
the best thing about the 15 minutes of
fighting is the fact that that's your
chance to let it all out you know be the
animal that you want to be and it feels
good it feels good to just let it out
but you're not always going to have that
in life so you have to find different
avenues to to let it out in and i've
been fortunate enough to learn how to do
that outside of fighting and now that i
felt like i've learned how to do that i
feel like
you know i'm ready to fight again yeah
that's you know the famous quote i mean
this goes back to what uh pat was saying
about jon jones you know the problem is
you stare into the darkness long enough
and eventually the darkness stares back
right so
you know if jon jones is trained to be a
fighter and there's nothing there's
nobody in front of the fight he's going
to start fighting himself yeah these
other guys find that you you you know
said one other thing life outside of
fighting you know for guys you see so
many great great great champions that
they they don't know when to walk away
you see you know ken shamrock i think
was still fighting you know guys like
when you saw you saw you know ben askren
going up there taking that you know i
saw you know brendan schaub says it's
not a dive i don't know what your
opinion on that is but i saw robbie
lawler put his fist with ben asking his
face and him not did not
him not go down so i don't know what
your thoughts are on ben askren versus
jake paul if you want to say him but
i mean
i don't know man
i don't know i mean look i'm not gonna
take a dive i'm not gonna let somebody
punch me in the face like that and take
a dive i mean i think jake just really
caught him really what about tyrone
woodley is there any chance he took a
dive because he got knocked out nah jake
jake caught him again
i mean listen i i i i hate to say it
because i was not
a fan of the jake paul the nepal
brothers do anything but
they they wanted me over they they
really
you got to respect them you got to
respect them because
i mean it's not easy what they did you
know how bad would you mess up jake paul
i mean i like to believe i'll mess him
up pretty bad but i mean you know jake
is doing some things now you know what
i'm saying he's he's dude you're in
boxing hall of fame
i'm just i'm just saying like i'm not a
boxer that's what i'm saying i'm not a
boss
what's the difference between the two
for those uh layman's uh out here uh
pace the timing the distance um you know
uh
the the the cadence of the punches you
know you know you got to be able to
understand that in order to you can't
just like jump into a boxing match and
just think that you've got a different
sport it's a totally different long
drive competition compared to 18 holes
of golf it's home run derby or dunk
contest be compared to basketball you
have to have
you know to to go up against him you got
he's gonna he's gonna grapple you he's
gonna he's he's gonna strike from the
outside he's gonna kick you with your
legs from every angle i mean like the
amount of stuff that you have to prepare
for is insane like for instance like t
wood is known for that big overhand
right but that was predicated off of the
fact that he had the ability to take you
down yeah so you had to respect the fact
that he could take you down so when
you're not even worrying about that
you're just it's just straight back it's
just straight boxing yeah so but by the
way so so here's a question you got
uh francis who's destroying people right
with a swing
and then you got tyson fury who is
undefeated and
one looks like a boxer the other one
looks like a bartender right even
what are you trying to say even he jokes
about no no he posted a picture the
other day says this guy looks like a
boxer this guy does not but this guy
whooped his ass like that's what he said
on his instagram post but if but if a
fury today
fights francis boxing obviously in the
other area it's a different story but
it's in the boxing by the boxing rules
does tyson still win 100
100 i mean uh listen listen listen as
today right right now i'm talking about
right now yeah
yeah i mean francis hasn't been boxing
right i mean listen francis can box but
to to
dismiss tyson fury just by the way his
body is you're dismissing his boxing
skill
tyson fury is extremely fast he has you
know
very good footwork you know he has very
good setups with his punches i mean
deontay walder i mean his skill level
when it comes to showing the straight
ones and twos may not be the cleanest
but
he he can he can box you know what i'm
saying wilder why why while they can
while they're combining so maybe wilder
francis is a better fighter that'll be a
better fight i see what you're saying i
i think i think that
i think that i think that um
if if um
deontay walder and and uh and francis
fought i like francis in that fight over
wilder over wilder i like france in that
fight because wilder throws some wild
punches when it comes
but if they connect you're going down
back to jake paul
he's just making mincemeat of these ufc
guys you brought up uh
but let's talk boxers where is he in an
actual boxing match if he's fighting a
real boxer you know like i i don't know
if yuri's brother's a good example and
he's weight class too though adam
because he's been fighting people where
is he in a real boxer okay something
that i'm clarifying right now is like
all right cool it's not the same thing
boxing ufc you know use the home run
derby versus a real baseball game if he
fights a real boxer where does that go
probably not well for him you know
because the truth of the matter is you
know he still makes a lot of amateur
mistakes when he's out there you know um
he he's fighting exactly who he needs to
be fighting and i think this is the
stick that he needs to stick with
because you know uh
he doesn't need to be fighting
any real boxers that's been fighting
since they were kids because of the
truth that matters he he will get
exposed
in that respect you know he's got 40
million reasons to keep messing up ufc
guys huh i mean i guess he's supposed to
fight mike tyson soon so i don't know
about that
on that pat i mean
that's that's what i heard i mean but if
he fighting mike tyson yeah where you at
with that mike is going to destroy him
because mike mike don't play boxing mike
don't play boxing might only be mike
would destroy him
mike 55. listen mike is a different
different animal altogether mike is
mike is something different like mike is
the kind of guy
who uh
like he's he's he's become very
civilized
but
he's still very very savage
very savage but up until what age
meaning 55 mike tyson will mess him up
65 55 he's seven years away from getting
social security
55 55 i don't know what we're talking
about he smokes a lot he takes a lot of
mushrooms so he's got different
perspective i mean mike trains too mike
is micah's not just he doesn't he
doesn't just do it to you know to get in
shape for a fight mike is training all
the time he's consistently training he's
been able to you know find a second win
when it comes to training he's been able
to find a second win when it comes to
the love of the sport
which pushed him out of the boxing in
general but now he loves it again and
now that he loves it again
he's he's he's into it you know he's
into boxing and he's
but by the way would you would you make
the comparison of jon jones and mike
tyson more than jon jones and dennis
rodman
would you would you make that like
you know a personality the the more the
extracurricular activities outside of
the ring would you make that comparison
um i would say no i mean
because
knowing mike tyson mike is a uh he's a
very cerebral guy mike is one of the
smartest guys that
that you that you're gonna that you're
gonna meet i would say when mike gets
himself in situations
is because he um
allowed himself to
uh like
get overwhelmed with a situation he
doesn't handle being overwhelmed really
well you know what i'm saying like mike
mike doesn't he doesn't you know that
pat and tyson were in the ring together
one time yeah it was pretty intense
would you what was you
what was the one thing well he
interviewed him in a row boxing yeah
but but you know what he is extremely
intense extremely smart but the reason
why you know gerard used the word case
study you know if you look at everybody
as a case study i'm a case study your
case study we're all case studies here
right but if you look at everybody as a
case study
mike
things changed when
the guy who believed in him passed away
so it was an event customer yeah that's
what i'm saying and i asked them the
question i wonder if something like that
happened to to john there is a very
interesting dynamic between a father and
a son
where the father earns the respect of
the son to the point where the son is
willing to take the feedback from the
father to not want to disappoint the
father that dynamic is a very powerful
dynamic when you know in heaven if
another man plays that role for you it
can really help shape your life right is
there something like that in john's life
i think that person was his mother okay
and his mother was uh somebody who um
you know she was a great woman you know
there's this woman when i was getting
ready to fight john in the height of our
beef you know she was blind but uh you
know she knew i walk into the room and
she's like is that a shot
and then her eyes are like yeah that's
rashad rashad i know you didn't walk in
the room without saying hi to me and she
was just like always making me speak to
her but she would just you know she's
like i know you and john going through
it but you know when she just like you
know give me give me love you know what
i'm saying so she was a very special
woman very spiritual woman and i feel
like she was um
john's you know spiritual anchor and i
feel like a lot of the things that we
see
in john now is is maybe him
dealing with you know shades of that
emotion yeah she passed away a few years
ago who was that for you
oh man who was that for me
i would say um i would say it's my mom
my my mama's my mama's uh is my rock you
know i can call my mom
and uh you know she always got some got
some advice rashad now listen i i know
you got a fight coming up with a shot
listen when you go out there rashad you
gotta hit richard you gotta hit and keep
him hit richard
it's great advice mom thank you i wasn't
gonna actually hit him
but you know based on that that that
almost sounded like that old uh cannabis
song back in the day with uh yeah with
the
second round knockout with mike tyson
cannabis man you gotta hit him second
round
yeah
yeah but now you can't under you can't
underestimate moms right my mom is an
undefeated fly weight in our house the
kitchen was the octagon and she's
undefeated
babs first round first round knockouts
if she calls you the kitchen you've done
something wrong welcome to the octagon
you're going down pat i think you were
going somewhere with your question about
john because your life changed forever
the day that your dad had a heart attack
right yeah no i'm listen for me
i might i dramatically change my life so
i i wonder when a
cormier says drama he can he's never
going to change and everybody i've
interviewed from the ufc side i've
talked to i've always asked who do you
think can one day replace dana white
i gotta tell you unanimously do you
think conor could do it no do you think
joe could do joe wouldn't want to do you
think this
almost everybody i've asked who could
replace dana's job is cormier i'm
telling you that's what a lot of people
maybe you disagree with that no i think
dc can't yeah sure so so they say dc so
i ask why because dana is straight up
and he'll tell you your flaws you
screwed up like dana will see on the
camera and say
what the hell was he doing throwing
something on the on the bus what are you
doing like what were you thinking or
what are you thinking jumping out or in
that one fight where khabib was like
give me the belt i want my belt let me
tell you something if i give you the
belt right now here's what i think is
going to happen this place is going to
go crazy shit's going to get ugly i'm
going to give it to you later i can
handle it i'm not giving you the both
like you those are not easy
conversations to have like the average
person will be like all right here you
go let me give you the belt no the guy
sticks and then for dc to say
a person doesn't make the same mistake
over and over and over and over and over
again right that's a tough thing to tell
somebody yeah you know that's a very
tough thing to say somebody so
does a dc
believe that
you know
and then i see a story with me the
change my dad and i have the biggest
debates all the time here's my dad and
his biggest debate i would have my
friends come over and say that i think
this guy's going to make a very big
impact in his life so no he's not i said
what are you talking about you know what
he would say
he would say look how short he is look
what he weighs he said this can't even
discipline his diet you think he can
discipline to work that's my dad how
brutal he was i had a friend of mine he
would come over two guys would come over
to our house he'd call both of them
gordo you know what gordon means gordon
is like
one of them
never showed up again the last time he
was in the room with my daddy was 25
he's 43 right now because he's afraid my
dad's going to say hey gordo hey gordon
that's my dad right how he is i said
that you can't talk to people like
though he's fat what do you want me to
tell him so he's gone better over the
years he's 79 now he's listening to this
year but he called this guy gordon
another guy he called him gordon george
palaio he says hey gordo when are you
going to fix that look at your pants it
doesn't fit when he get my dad would
straight up and by the way my dad
is he the sweetest guy or what he's yeah
nicest guy you'll meet right most
cerebral smartest yeah like it's almost
like a real life socrates real talk just
a chill guy he's five how tall is he i
i'm six four six five how tall is my dad
what would you say my dad is i think
he's about uh five nine i wanna give him
an inch or two okay so five five seven
but he's just like like this yeah right
you know what george did with it was
that he changed
george will make three million dollars
this year at 34 years old 35 years old
right but he changed he he decided to
say maybe this guy's right you know what
i'm saying maybe there's somebody that's
given a feedback so one day we're having
a debate like that and i say dad i think
that guy can change he'll never change
that i think that guy can change patrick
i'm telling you he'll never change you
think
everybody is willing to work their asses
off like you're working what do you
think the world is like that guy is not
going to change
he was right half the time i was right
half the time okay meaning there were
guys that i believe but i bank on
believing people can change the story in
my life is i believe people can change
right
there's a part of it where you wonder
it's so deep rooted to the core
that
you know
i mean
nike contract
you know what i mean the only ufc fight
that's ever been cancelled was 151 with
dan henderson yeah you know this it's
the only one ever that you know dana's
like
and he second chance third chance four
chance all of this stuff
um
you're talking about jon jones here
right yeah jon jones was going to fight
what was the fight it was another fight
and that understands johnson anthony
johnson and then he got her and then you
know test deposit right
yeah so all of these things and the last
minute dana doesn't want to cancel a
fight are you freaking kidding me who
the hell wants to cancel a fight it's a
bad look on the sport right you have to
refund cancellations all this
media is going to write about it they're
struggling they're going out of business
nobody's watching them anymore who the
hell wants to answer all these questions
right
um
so yeah i i i wonder who's in his ear
well danny even said dana said it's it
you know it's impossible for me to bet
on jon jones on a weekend in vegas
it's impossible for me to bet on jon
jones do you know how do you know how
tough that is for
for you for for a guy who has given
people not just him he's given people so
many seconds he's like jimmy johnson
jimmy johnson like to go get people who
got arrested yeah who did that was his
motto right even
bill belichick is good at doing that he
did that with a few different guys
this isn't an industry where you're
pulling guys out of cornell totally
right you know
but listen neither is listen michael
what did you talk about miami was you're
going to miss me that's what i mean no
no no no no there's a place in this
world for pirates though bro you know
what i'm saying
i get there is there's a place for
pirates but i think when
jon sends i'll change i think he wants
to that's the difference like you see
john's interview and he says i i'm gonna
change i want to change i think he wants
to
then there is somebody else in the ear
who is that is the right person in the
ear is the person willing to listen to
the person in the air but bro let me
give you a different perspective i i
guarantee i guarantee you well here's my
question and i'm going to open it up for
you
hypothetically i don't know jon jones
anywhere near where you guys everyone
here has said that he's the number one
guy of all time everyone
why would he change maybe what is
keeping him freaking mad and doing that
is what
is the reason that he's number one i
actually i can't believe it like tiger
woods when tiger woods changed he wasn't
talking with him
why would he change that's a literal
great point yeah they happen from uh
once again but that's not the point
though listen
give it to great great great example
but tiger woods his example was 16 porn
stars guys this this guy and he was
winning masters yeah no no but that's
not the point though the point that
tiger gets credit on what he said which
is not everybody can do this
we have a guy i work with jose gaitan
okay
we're sitting in my office one time i'm
interviewing this guy who wants to work
with us jose sitting over here i'm
sitting over we're in north church
california which is the earthquake
capital of the world right
sit and talk so so johnny tell me about
your background who were you in high
school i'm asking them all these
questions
all of a sudden a
massive earthquake is going in the
middle of the interview
glass is going like this shit's falling
down no joke
this guy i look to the right to look at
the window i looked to the left this
guy's running out the window right
running out the door he's out he left
the office he went outside
no no not guy tom the other guy here's
jose
oh
so bad what
we should probably leave
what do you think i said yeah he just
goes you know real slow
gets up and starts walking out jose dude
a hurricane could hit a r earthquake
could hit he's still going to be texting
this series
but what i'm saying is like a people who
can balance shit's not going right in
your personal life and you're still
winning tiger could pull that off right
not a lot of people can't do that jon
jones could pull that off not a lot of
people can't do that
but for every story like that you hear
there's a ton of stories that end with a
horror story and this guy's got a family
this guy's got people that love him and
at the end of the day uh i get like even
michael michael was reckless totally
getting michael was reckless but to what
level though
taylor i mean it goes on and on yeah
lawrence taylor that story is not didn't
end well lauren still could have had a
completely different career for himself
how much better credit though the
promise
not the sport life is bigger than sports
though life is bigger than sports yeah
the problem is some sometimes these
athletes you know
they have this this dark passenger like
this other side to themselves that
allows them to rise to the occasion
and and
that darkness needs the need needs to
eat it needs to feed you know so you
have to do dark things in order to feed
it and
sometimes they over indulge in it you
know and it becomes and it takes over
who they are you know but you have to be
able to
uh be able to understand the difference
between the two you have to understand
when it's time to feed the beast yeah
and when it's time not to you know and
and if you
are getting over indulging in and
defeating it then you're out of balance
because it's all it's all it's all such
a good point
for example you know jordan peterson
says what you got to be a monster be a
monster be a monster totally get it uh
you know tim grover in the book
relentless i don't know if you've read
it or not he talks about how all the
great ones have a vice like the internal
vice that we deal with everybody here we
all sin in a different way but ain't
nobody in your free if people went
through your search history or they went
through your phone text and the way you
done some conversations behind closed
doors with people we would all be
embarrassed right now with some of the
that we've done right
but then you know we had sammy double
garvano comes and we go to
a restaurant casa d'angelo
i don't know if you know sammy the
bullets yeah simon okay so we go to casa
we're sitting we're having dinner one
guy shows up john mason
okay and he sits in the corner we're
having dinner
sammy looks at john
and he keeps staring at him right and
john
john was a wanted to come he was dying
to come but he didn't want to die to
come you know what i mean like one of
those situations
so he said hey hey sammy hey sammy how
are you he's not even making eye contact
so mario starts joking around telling
sammy sami i just want to let you know
while i was outside john was talking
major smack about your friend
[Laughter]
john's life johnny mays no no i wasn't
he's lying no when john is like
literally like doesn't realize that
mario and samuel are playing a joke on
this guy sure okay
but here's the part so
you know sammy's capable
that's the part
the fact that he can go to a very very
dark side you know that's like the the
part about having a gun you don't have a
gun to use it every single day just
because you have it you have a gun so
the other person says hey how you doing
everything good awesome great thank you
so much for coming to our liquor store
now get the hell out of here right yeah
i'm capable i think john
we all know you're capable but doug just
like you know what i mean because
this thing is
look you know if you're his agent you're
his manager you're writing well you know
this part of darkness that's part of
this how big of a contract with that
nike contract i've been for john
i mean he would he would have jumped
into a different stratosphere when it
comes to who he was yeah that's a 100
million dollar contract yeah yeah it's
going to be a massive contract you're
set right well i just didn't want to do
it you know so those are those are the
things that for me i i you know you win
in life and we typically forget who gave
us that one council or who was there in
that moment that tells us to do this and
to do that and we were about to screw up
where you make that additional phone
call you know what i mean you make that
phone call to somebody you gotta if you
were to make a list of names of people
that impacted your life you'd probably
come up with 20 30 40 names and say at
this point in my life i was 17 this
person said this at 18 my wrestling
coach said this at 19 a bartender i was
working with the boss said this at 19
and a half my mom said this at 20 and a
half the girl that left me said this
you know you got it yeah so but i think
i think the problem is also is the fact
that you know
we're we're
putting this on you know who does he
have around him at the end of the day
you it has to come from here you know
what i'm saying and i feel
i may sound like you hit me for saying
this but i think five grams of mushrooms
will set john
i'll tell you what it'd be a lot better
for his career than five grams of white
stuff that's for sure what do you think
that would actually do for huh because
nobody gets better when they do cocaine
i'm gonna tell you this other than dewey
cox
what would the mushrooms do for if he
did if he did the toad which is five
meow dmt not the regular stuff that
people do with the you know the
the other you know um
that right there would would show him
something you know because it's a um
it's a totally different experience but
at the same time
you uh
you're almost reborn at that moment you
know it's a medicine that just
completely just changes everything that
you even know as as reality and even
yourself so i think he needs something
powerful like that because what he's
searching for he may not even know
anymore you know he just may be feeling
that something is is not right and he's
trying to chase it so they call it
chasing the dragon and you never catch
it never catch it
rashad have you uh people see you on the
street you go to a bar you go to a party
do people still try to like act like
they're tough enough to take like do you
do you have that happen or most people
are like listen this is my resume my
name is rashad evans i will destroy it
do average guys try to
act tough around you or no no they know
they don't they don't they
ever gone to a really good street fight
a really good street fight
you have i got into yeah like a really
good one that you remember like i mean i
i've gotten to a street fight as a
professional athlete that's what i'm
saying yeah that part not in high school
like a professional athlete yeah i have
what was that like well i was i was
staying at this hotel in um in toronto
filming this movie and these guys came
back and they were being really loud and
they're like knocking on all the doors
as they're walking by
and i just got back from being you know
from shooting it was probably like
around 2 30. how would you in the
morning i'm like maybe maybe 30 years
old so peak yeah yeah yeah so it's a bad
bad time bad time
so i um i go i uh put my head out the
door and i do in my old man's voice i'm
like hey guys why don't you just uh
settle down you know just you got this
voice
he's got some good voices
i live in bocas
did you kids get off my lawn
son of the
so i say that to him and then they
started getting lippy right so i'm just
like laughing and then i'm like all
right guys just just calm down so uh as
i stuck my out the window at the door
they started walking down
to how many guys by the way there's
three of them okay there's three guys
walk down to my door
and i'm still liking you know still like
in joking around mold but these guys are
kind of inebriated and they're kind of
like kind of pressure reaction so i have
my door open and they're standing right
in front of my door and they're
threatening me they're gonna do things
to me i said look if you cross into my
room
i'm gonna let you have it
so i see one of the guys like that's
more of the agitator than the rest of
them the other two just kind of like
backing him up and then he walks forward
and he doesn't even get to my room i
just started feeding him and i started
hitting him mushrooms of course
yeah mushrooms
now to start hitting him and then i just
started hitting his buddies and then uh
the security guards came and you know i
didn't get kicked out of the hotel but
it was uh they didn't know who you were
or they knew who you were they didn't
know there was no way they knew who you
were that's what i'm saying how bad did
they get messed up i fed them pretty
good
so if you can beat up
year olds fed them at the same time how
many 10 year olds do you think
[Laughter]
it's like a step brother
by the way is this a segway for our
friend paul to walk in listen are we
ready to look at the mazvidal video
because we went through street fight i
kind of want to see what he's going to
say even if we watch a couple minutes of
it before we go to paul video go ahead
go ahead uh gerard just real quick you
before we get to paul you fought
chocolate down chuck liddell when i was
growing up the iceman was the like i
mean he was untouchable and then he got
touched and he seemed to never be the
same fighter again and the same thing
happened with roy jones that was the
greatest of all time tarver hit him with
the overhand right and he was never the
same fighter again
do you think the concept of being a shot
fighter is a real thing do you think you
lose a step and then the follow-up to
that is do you think mcgregor is ever
going to be the same guy ever again
where's the book out uh you can't you
can't lose a step for sure 100 you know
a lot of guys when they take a big shot
like that you know it's all about doing
the right rehab you know when you don't
get your neck and everything looked at
and you don't you know um
restore the body give yourself enough
time off then that button is easier to
press you know but then at a certain age
you know it's easier to turn that button
off so
you you only have so many fights in you
you know and you and if you take too
many shots too early then they'll fight
is it the actual shots is it is it that
the you lose that that air of
invincibility people aren't as afraid to
come after you is it you actually lose a
physical step or you had a hole there
the whole time like maybe roy jones had
that overhand right held the whole time
just nobody threw it before tarver it's
just what happens that these guys are
untouchable and then all of a sudden
three four five losses in a row it's a
combination of everything you know it's
a part of the fact that they can't take
a shot then it's another part of the
fact that they're not used to taking a
shot and then you know when you do get
hit with a shot you kind of go into
panic mode because you're not used to
that or you start having those thoughts
running your mind like oh now this
happened again you know you start to
start to worry about it and um you know
you're not able to recover so it's a
combination of of different things so
when you look at a guy like mcgregor is
the book out on him does he need to
completely re redesign his training
module or is it is it just time he had
his run and it's over i think he can he
can rebuild you know i'm looking at
mcgregor now have you guys seen mcgregor
now massive oh my god he's he's big he's
big there's no there's no water i guess
or anything like that going on i don't
know i mean he's still in a testing pool
so he has to be doing everything legal i
don't know how he's i don't know what he
looks like he's trying to fight in the
heavyweight looks like he's a gorilla
yeah i mean listen if he's still trying
to fight 155 i don't know how he's going
to make that weight not going to happen
no he he's really massive right now what
do you think he weighs right now 180
something yeah maybe 190. i mean he's
got he's got like that
that that built where his shoulders look
like it's hard to wipe his ass
so it's you would know i do know what
you're saying
but i mean it's a i think he can do i
mean if anybody if anybody who can come
back and do it as mcgregor because
mcgregor has he was propelled by belief
you know what i'm saying he's one of
those guys who
you know was like the ali he said it and
he went out and did it so he can do that
again
here's a video of mazvidal
street fighting back in the days
uh yeah miami so but put the audio so we
can hear it in jorts look at the jorts
nobody rocks shorts and his belt is not
even at the right loop
can you move that one okay there you go
that's great technique though man he has
you see how his hands are right so he's
catching everything so the guy even if
he does land he's getting kind of
deflected off of his hands he's not
blinking either i mean he can't teach
that no
this guy's way bigger way bigger but
he's doing it
doing a good thing going to the body now
he's gonna go over top
how old is he here about this i'm
curious 20.
[Music]
the composure though that's that's what
i'm looking at see how composed
[Applause]
still going to the body like a kimbo
slice in the background bro
oh oh oh oh the spinning backhand
but you know what it is though like this
guy is getting off on him too but it's
the posturing that
george is doing afterwards to let the
guy know that he hasn't landed anything
so the guy's losing confidence wow
so that plays as big of a role you
imagine the guy next door at the taco
joint just waiting 20 minutes like wow i
just i'm about to sell 80 times like
what i just wanted this is in miami by
the way i do this every week yeah
[Music]
see
oh
what what is the what is the
laws against street fights like i knew
you had none of this is legal
no no you were doing the underground you
know the fight club type of thing
all of this is illegal right you can't
this is illegal
a fight is illegal but a street fight
paying betting that's that's the part
that's illegal that's illegal yeah
this is a throwback man to when they
used to have fights on the barges
outside of uh new york city because
fighting was illegal in the turn of the
century so they'd get on the barges
float out and then they'd have these
these massive fights
see now now that jorge got his time and
now he knows he got his time and it's
over at this point yeah well this is
also why there's rounds right i mean oh
that knee got him
that's what you're saying a heavyweight
just has to get around once right that's
it
it's the posture it's the posture that
he has and he's not
bro and you think kobe is going to take
down mastodon
i mean i love mazda man he's my guy but
i just think that kobe
he has wrestling he has a wrestling that
wrestling
is just is at another level because he
doesn't stop the pace that he's able to
wrestle not a lot of people can handle
that pace you know it's all about pace
you know and if you're a guy like colby
covington who can keep pushing the pace
and go and go and go it's hard to defeat
a guy like that you know and and
mozville you know they trained together
before so there there's a lot more to it
you know what i'm saying and there's
there's more
to the story you know what i'm saying
kobe didn't call this guy out he didn't
call jorge out because he didn't think
that he could beat him there's something
that happened in the training that he
remembers that mazda remembers that is
going to play a little bit of animosity
there though oh yeah this one this one
is real animosity and it's been for a
few years of animosity it's not like
it's a new thing yeah it's it's been
brewing for a while man but you know
it's but you know it's hard to to go
against uh mazda you know what i'm
saying because mazda you know he came
out on the scene and he he uh really
showed who he was within the last couple
years and it seems like a lot of things
have come together for him but
i mean kobe covington is
yeah and usman beat both of them though
yeah who does he think is going to win
because that's your guy i don't know i i
would say if i was a guest for him i'll
say he'll think that kobe cummings is
going to do that behind kobe is like the
only guy that's giving us man even a
little bit of problem i mean the last
few fights
yeah i mean if it goes if it goes the
sixth round and that last covington was
coming on i couldn't believe it i
thought he was done we went to europe
there's something very unique about kobe
by the way uh there's there's a dog
fight in him yeah you know there's a
very unique uh thing about him about
mazdal here's the thing about masuda you
saw how that guy just not uh punched a
mozzarella all of a sudden and
mozwarella was dropped
that could happen with jorge jorge has a
weapon and if one of these things
connect
kobe's got a great uh you know he can he
can take it yeah but mazvidal can give
it it'll be interesting what happens i
think vegas is way towards kobe than
mazda is uh is usman looking at gaichi
next or is he looking to move up in
weight class
um
i think i think they might be trying to
fight uh who is it who's it like uh
who's it uh edwards or something like
that oh edwards yeah not gaity really
but they're they're training partners oh
so they this is the whole like leota
machido and uh anderson
well geichi's at 155 or now he's coming
up though isn't he no
after the chandler fight he's staying
down there you gonna say it on there
yeah yeah gerard don't ever second guess
paul why don't you come on up here let's
see paul's history of getting punched in
the face by chuck chuck
[Music]
yeah
uh here you go play this paul was a lot
bigger here too all right watch this we
don't have audio oh my gosh you know he
only has one glove just one glove
there's young pat someone hurt his neck
when i'm chuck
hey paul
my brother how you feeling buddy i
really enjoyed it
okay he said it was forty percent okay
he has some grace but he didn't try to
yeah a little harder okay
look how big mario was too mario
that was good though he got him there
now watch mario goes to the couch
[Music]
by the way when we asked everyone who
they'd rather get hit everyone chose
mario but uh unfortunately we got paul
here so no no paul come on up here paul
line it up let
rashad put the gloves on nice let's see
how this is going to be somebody stand
behind paul and case the uh the apollo
creed special here
can you move the camera so they can do
it here yeah somebody get behind paul
just in case
aren't you going to make it fair and do
it left-handed
just to uh nancy okay so you're
preparing with nancy that says a lot
good for you graphic designer punch you
in the face okay rashad
he was also talking trash about your
mama oh
here we go dude you just
you really yeah we're here on the ppd
podcast
and we got rashad
he's not going to get punched in the
face by rashad evans so we're going to
see what's going to happen here so what
am i doing is that right in the front go
over here yeah go over here because
uh you got to start speaking russian
give them give them get them ready for
the weekend you want to get uh
behind paul okay somebody's looking
serious just go stand there just in case
believe me last time it was uh
no no gerard will be right behind you
just think we need the uh hey good luck
paul
nice to meet you you're about to get
punched in the face
ufc hall of famer hug it out we need the
drago recording if he dies he dies
i think we have one we got to do that
remember
no no it was i thought it was like a
hundred percent
i was gonna say i thought he gave it
like
if paul is trying to set himself up
you know it wasn't a full punch in the
face
ufc hall of famer about to knock out
paul
can we get a weigh-in picture here
it's okay buddy
david ready
[Laughter]
[Music]
he said thank you
hey hug it out guys
seven eight
nine ten
we're out all right so paul we need
commentary tell us the difference
chocolate del rashad evans
okay here we go
yeah i mean
way harder
[Laughter]
holy there we go
i mean one of the good news is those
those are the 16 so when chuck hit us it
was a smaller glove too
but
yeah you're feeling it though
hey paul the good news you got the day
off buddy yeah
i'm sorry man well you're amazing
we appreciate the bravery these gloves
you can kind of feel the knuckle coming
through a little bit
hang on here these are the tyson fury
models man somebody uh somebody get
rashad a sharpie we got to get that
signed
wow
can we do it again
tell me you're joking okay good because
he was going to do it to you if you
weren't rolling not the fall oh we
didn't have it
paul would you like tickets
dude his eyes are glossed over it's not
this is no bs your eyes are you talking
about
why don't we get policy first of all
well lunch is on us yeah why don't we
get police you're probably one of the
only people i know that's been punched
by two hall of famers ufc hall of famers
so you ought to be proud of yourself to
not get paid for any by the way
how do you feel right now about you know
i feel bad man i feel bad about it i
don't feel bad you all right though
what was it like getting punched like by
liddell in the ring is he the hardest
puncher you ever faced he's one of them
man chuck chuck clicked me with a couple
of shots and uh
it was like
it felt all the way down to my toes man
you felt that all the way down
oh wow yeah
like like just shocked you're nervous
like an electric shock interesting wow
that's like the next the next level
stuff because you've been punched a lot
and then somebody that's what that's
what happens before you get knocked out
before you get knocked out like you get
hit and then your feet like you feel it
down to your feet and then you can't
feel your legs anymore and you see
people start getting a stanky leg it's
because they can't feel their feet leaky
leg yeah never heard of tournaments this
terminology well rampage term that that
that's what he said to me after i got
knocked out by machida so
but uh yeah so when you it goes to your
legs and then you can't feel your legs
anymore so that's why the legs start
getting funny and then you go down so if
liddell's not the hardest you've been
hit though huh
i would say keith jardine was the
hardest idea he's jordan jardine hits
like a mack truck man really yeah what a
name from the past keith jardine holy
the dean of maine this might be a good
segue to talk about who you're gonna
knock out this weekend or this coming up
uh fight in what less than 10 days yep
i'm fighting uh gabriel checko
from vegas uh mostly grappler but he's
got some hands he's he can you know he
can uh he can throw some punches big
bigger guys and that's january 28th in
miami in miami you know where the fight
is exactly the location it's gonna be at
the um
the old nickelodeon uh building they
bought that out and they've done a
phenomenal job of making it like the
apec center
and uh it's uh it's habib did an amazing
job like in the whole production team
they did an amazing job with this
facility is he representing you are you
with him now with his camp now or um
well i'm with ali abdelaziz and we're
you know we're stable mates with ali but
uh it's um
the eagle promotions
and i mean you know habib they spared no
expense with this place it's a state of
the yard it's really props to him good
for him you think he's coming back or no
you think he's ever gonna
nah i think man i seen habibi but b was
probably like 210 pounds no no he's a
big dude but not in a bad way he's just
like oh not like the prince in that
scene way like no no he's he's got he's
he's he's baited he's big though he's
just
wide back just look like he's just been
eating and just doing it i've always
heard that about anderson silva man when
guys i trained with like edson barbosa
and those guys and dante rivera they'd
say like silva walks around like 225 and
cuts down into the 180s like the dude
yeah he's a he's a big dude too yeah
amazing sharpie
homeboy sharpie what should we expect
for the fight you said he's a grappler
too i guess diego silva you know you
showed the world that you could grapple
yeah and you pulled that out of the bag
and in the strategy for that fight what
does what should we expect for this
fight
um
i don't know you know the truth of the
matter is that you know he he's a
grappler so i'm sure he's probably going
to try to get me down to the ground
be on top and try to work at submission
games uh
but he knows that i'm a wrestler too as
well
so you know he's going to be willing to
exchange with me uh probably try to
catch me with some punches but um
i don't know man it's just you know it's
hard to say what's going to happen in
the fight situation especially since
i've been out for so long and you know
this was the last time you fought
was it 2018
dude this is
four three four almost four years yeah
yeah wow are you excited are you nervous
how you i mean you've been fought four
years almost yeah i'm excited i'm
nervous i'm all those things i'm uh i'm
i have a wave of roller coaster emotions
but you know this is this is why i
wanted to do it you know to be able to
feel this feeling again i mean there's
nothing like
the feeling of a fight because you know
you're not so much fighting an opponent
you're fighting yourself you know and
that's where that's where the true
challenge is is really fighting yourself
to you know bring yourself mentally
there in order to be able to bring
yourself physically there respect i love
it well um listen man
i hope we help with the tune-up with
paul yes
that was
just that was uh paul is by the way just
to look on paul's face if you want to
focus on paul real quick he seems very
thankful yeah uh he's extremely grateful
he seems like uh he's got another story
to tell paul you could take the head
gear off now we're not gonna hit you no
no no no don't do that it's holding his
skull together
well rochelle we are 100 rooting for you
bro thank you awesome you've got a lot
of valuetainers out there that maybe
have never heard did you actually get
into some of these topics and
something tells me you got a whole new
fan base that's rooting for man
appreciate you for coming out this was
great and we're gonna have you sign one
of these
uh
one of these out here pick and choose
and sign it so we
know
my man was here with us guys uh we're
gonna do the next podcast as well do we
have tomorrow tomorrow who's tomorrow
with who's with
oh john
adams
that's right danielle adam and john
stossel tomorrow on the podcast we'll
see you guys there take care everybody
bye bye bye bye
you